Trascrizione: Agnese Giacomelli
Revisore: Michele Gianella
(Musica)
Qual è la mia idea di bellezza?
Per voi c'è il suono,
quello che avete sentito;
per me c'è la vibrazione.
Sono nata sorda, a causa
di una rosolia congenita.
Prima che nascessi,
i miei genitori sapevano
che ci sarebbero state
delle conseguenze per me -
non sapevano ancora quali -
ma quando, poi sono nata,
hanno capito che non sentivo
perché non reagivo agli stimoli sonori.
E questa è stato un po' la mia fortuna,
perché hanno iniziato a informarsi
su come poteva essere
affrontata la sordità.
C'erano diverse possibilità:
e sarei dovuta rimanere nel silenzio,
ma dovevo in qualche modo
comunicare con il mondo.
E così ho iniziato a parlare,
perché i miei genitori mi hanno fatto fare
logopedia per ben dodici anni.
E poi c'è stato un incontro importante
con una musicoterapeuta che si chiama
Giulia Cremaschi Trovesi,
che sta a Bergamo.
E vi suggerisco di andare a vedere
quello che fa, perché è interessante;
ha lavorato per oltre 40 anni
con i bambini sordi,
e aveva scoperto che in realtà
questi bambini sentivano,
percepivano la musica non con l'orecchio
ma con il corpo, attraverso il corpo.
E così è stato anche per me.
E perché il violoncello?
La signora Giulia aveva consigliato
ai miei genitori il violoncello,
perché è uno strumento che ha le frequenze
simili a quelle della voce umana,
e questo mi sarebbe stato utile
per superare la mia sordità,
ma per stimolare il mio ascolto.
E così io, a tre anni,
ho iniziato a frequentare una scuola
di musica privata, qui a Udine.
Ed ho iniziato il mio
lungo percorso musicale.
Diciamo che questo ha portato
dei buoni risultati,
perché a un certo punto
c'è stato un episodio,
circa quando avevo dodici anni di età,
che, siccome prima il mio orecchio destro
era completamente morto, per così dire,
non sentivo nulla,
un giorno, una mattina,
ho messo su l'apparecchio
e sono corsa da mia mamma
e le ho detto "mamma sento, sento!".
Ma come sento: certo,
nel limite delle mie possibilità.
Era successo
che l'orecchio destro si era risvegliato
e si era bilanciato
con l'orecchio sinistro:
poi, gli esami audiometrici
hanno confermato questo episodio.
E poi, portavo anche
gli apparecchi acustici,
quindi io sono stata
a contatto con i suoni.
Quindi ho iniziato a sentire le vibrazioni
e non era scontato che potessi
anche imparare a parlare.
La tecnologia, poi,
è migliorata nel tempo,
perché quando io sono nata
eravamo negli anni '80,
e ancora non era così diffuso
il fatto che le persone sorde
potessero parlare e persino suonare.
E questo era anche un po'
il guaio, diciamo;
io dovevo confrontarmi
con un mondo che sente,
mentre io non sentivo.
Però se vediamo una che parla e suona,
allora magari ci viene il dubbio,
"ma allora ci sente".
Diciamo che ero a metà strada:
non sentivo ma sentivo,
un po' entrambe le cose.
Questo poi, il violoncello mi ha messo -
diciamo che è stato uno strumento
che mi ha dato tanto.
Le difficoltà maggiori, poi,
sono state quelle di dover
affrontare l'intonazione.
L'intonazione era proprio
la spina nel fianco. Perché?
Per un motivo: io sentivo la vibrazione,
però la vibrazione mi dava l'idea
delle frequenze basse e quelle alte:
quindi suoni gravi, suoni acuti.
Però quando poi andiamo,
entriamo più nel dettaglio
io riesco a distinguere un do da un re,
però a un certo punto non riesco più
a distinguere un do meno da un do più,
chiamiamolo così,
un re meno o un re più,
un re crescente e un re un po' calante.
Questo perché?
Perché per voi, forse,
che sentite il suono,
la bellezza sta anche
nel sentire gli armonici,
però gli armonici
vengono captati dall'orecchio,
l'orecchio che riesce
a sentire questa differenza.
Nella vibrazione non c'è
questa informazione, diciamo;
o meglio, c'è però ho bisogno
del fenomeno della risonanza.
Le corde vibrano: però ho bisogno
di un riferimento, uno strumento,
un'altra persona che mi fa una nota.
Se mi suona un do, o un re,
e lo suono anche io,
riesco a sentire se la vibrazione è uguale
oppure c'è qualcosa di diverso,
qualcosa che non va.
E però, quando suono da sola,
le note si susseguono una dopo l'altra;
e lì diciamo che non riesco a sentire
il rapporto fra una nota
e quella successiva.
C'è una relazione fra le note.
Perché?
Perché per me il suono è bello comunque:
che sia intonato, o poco intonato,
è sempre un suono,
e io riesco ad essere
appagata dalla vibrazione.
Poi ci sono anche
gli armonici, nella voce;
e io teoricamente sapevo cosa fossero,
sapevo che esistessero,
ma nella pratica l'ho scoperto
tantissimo tempo dopo.
Per la precisione, giusto un anno fa:
un anno fa, ho scoperto
gli armonici nella mia voce,
anche se il canto lo avevo già fatto
perché mi serviva, proprio,
per aprire la mia voce,
e poter comunicare
anche attraverso di essa.
La sordità è difficile da capire,
perché è una perdita uditiva
intorno ai 90 decibel
e quindi è molto profonda.
Vuol dire che perché io possa
sentire qualcosa senza apparecchi
deve passare un camion,
un enorme camion molto grosso e rumoroso,
oppure uno djambè africano,
oppure una porta che sbatte violentemente,
quindi un rumore molto forte.
Addirittura, non sentivo il mio cane
che abbaiava vicino a me.
Infatti, spesso succedeva
che il mio cane di giorno
era tranquillo, buono:
"Com'è tranquillo: non abbaia mai"
E invece, di notte, lui aveva capito
che io non sentivo, e quindi si sfogava.
Una volta mi è arrivato un messaggio
da una vicina di casa.
M'ha detto: "Ma per caso sei uscita,
e hai lasciato il cane solo?
Le ho detto "No, io sono in casa".
perché stava abbaiando,
stava facendo un gran casino.
E quindi, ho dovuto coglierlo sul fatto:
una notte ho dormito con gli apparecchi.
Mi sono svegliata
quando ha iniziato ad abbaiare,
ho acceso la luce
e lui è rimasto impalato a guardarmi.
(Risate)
(Applausi)
Poi ci sono stati dei miglioramenti,
anche nella comprensione dell'italiano.
Quando, circa due, tre anni fa,
ho deciso di prendere l'auto
col mio cane e il mio gatto
e sono partita all'estero;
ho fatto un giro intorno all'Europa,
lavorando nelle fattorie:
volevo capire qualcosa di più
sulla coltivazione biologica.
E però, in questo viaggio
c'erano tre presupposti:
uno era che in quell'anno
avevo deciso di non riacquistare
gli apparecchi acustici,
perché soffrivo di acufeni
e volevo stare in silenzio:
significava partire nel silenzio assoluto.
Il secondo presupposto
era che avrei dovuto
comunicare solo in inglese.
Se ci ho messo così tanto
per imparare l'italiano,
figuriamoci con l'inglese:
ero proprio da capo.
E poi c'era, anche, il fatto
che comunque io avrei potuto
appagare il mio senso visivo,
anche se quello uditivo
lo dovevo mettere da parte.
Però, attraverso la vista potevo godere
della bellezza dei posti che ho visitato.
Ho visto tanti bellissimi posti,
tantissimi colori di verde,
giallo, il cielo blu.
E il bello è anche proprio questo,
cogliere le sfumature
e contemplare quello che ci arriva.
Io, nel tempo, ho sempre sviluppato
un amore per i luoghi sin dall'infanzia,
sono proprio stati
il perno della mia vita,
perché ogni luogo che io ho vissuto
per me rappresentava qualcosa,
ma in modo molto intenso,
e diventava ricorrente nei miei sogni;
e mi aiutava, anche,
a sviluppare la fantasia.
E quando ero piccola, ho avuto la fortuna
che i miei nonni avevano
una villa gigantesca,
era proprio un castello
con una torre, del 1400.
Io ci ho vissuto per almeno
10 anni della mia vita:
e per una bambina, questo luogo
era veramente un luogo magico e fatato,
perché ogni stanza era tutta da scoprire.
Quindi, c'è una bellezza
che appartiene ai nostri sensi.
C'è quella visiva, c'è quella uditiva.
Come vi ho detto prima, ogni suono per me
è bello purché non sia rumore,
è bello a prescindere dall'intonazione.
Magari il problema è quando,
in quello che noi percepiamo,
si intromette il nostro giudizio,
perché siamo condizionati un po' da sempre
a giudicare qualsiasi cosa.
Giudico quello che sento,
giudico quello che vedo:
però, questo mi fa perdere
la bellezza del momento.
E quando io, sentendo le sfumature,
percepisco la differenza tra una cosa
rispetto a un'altra,
devo ritornare un attimo a contemplare,
lasciando stare i pensieri
che nascono in quel momento.
E questo mi permette
di eliminare il giudizio.
È come quando noi osserviamo un tramonto:
in un tramonto, io non è
che mi metto a dire:
ma qui ci va un po' di giallo,
ci vorrebbe un po' più di blu,
ancora un po' di rosso".
Così cerco di renderlo più bello
di quello che magari già è.
E così, ormai,
la bellezza del momento è sfumata,
e il tramonto è passato,
e non mi sono goduta l'attimo.
E questo, quindi, non va bene.
Allora, per godere appieno della bellezza
basta rimanere lì in silenzio,
e ascoltare.
(Musica)
Il punto di partenza siamo sempre noi,
e la bellezza va cercata in quel centro.
(Applausi)